how many girls have started to make a
living off of only fans now that would
just normally have a job and never get
paid the same amount of money well it's
one of the reasons why we're not seeing
that many hot chicks working at Chipotle
I think is that what it is the only fans
I think it's gonna it's definitely but
how they get an audience
like just because you're hot and you
show your [__] they bait through
their Instagram yeah
dude you know no two [__] are the
same is that true I'm sure it's like a
fingerprint I
they're gonna use that from now on to
get into the bank
it's like your retina scan that's how do
you get into Dan bilzerian's house
[Laughter]
I mean if you
are making like stupendous amounts of
money on only fans oh it's baffling but
do you do you also think Joe that whoa
only fans is over 1 million creators so
one well let's imagine that's an that's
worldwide
up from 70 000 in 2019 so all those
people jumped on board during the
pandemic
that makes sense this is what I start to
worry about that it's going to be like
every what is this called a gig economy
no what is this okay no gig economy is
like uber right okay is it would you
think of only fans does that count yeah
I mean you could get a gig they make a
video for a specific person same same
kind of thing do you think it's gonna
get to a point right where
if we start losing jobs right and
there's less jobs and more people are on
like only fans right that you're
basically have chicks out there like
literally people women holding each
other at gunpoint like you know
subscribe to my [__] stuff like that
like
you know what I'm saying like I don't
know what you're saying you know help
Jamie can you pull up some help
I need some help man like I always have
this vision of like two Uber drivers
like you're you're gonna be my uh
um
I'm your you're my ride or you know what
I'm saying you're my like
like it's like people like it's all just
digital it's all online and it's just
like people just like subscribe to me
now you know like literally at gunpoint
like that's how bad it's gonna get I
don't think that's gonna happen but I
think there's gonna be a lot of people
that are doing that to make a living the
problem is where's the money coming from
is it going to be subscribers paying
other subscribers is it going to be like
a hierarchy like someone who makes like
a million dollars a month paying someone
who makes a hundred thousand dollars a
month who pays someone who makes ten
thousand dollars a month is it is it
going to be a pyramid scheme for [__]
yeah
yeah I'd almost get to buy a fake [__]
somewhere and put it out there I don't
think that's good enough I think you
have to have the whole body attached to
it like what do most girls on only fans
do do they show like bikini pictures
like what are they doing showing feet
there's bikini pictures I know that
there's like meetups where like manager
companies like have them all go to like
a location together like at the beach
and then they do like you know tit
touching and like uh
you know uh they get together melon and
each other's cry you know like stuff oh
and so that gets everybody excited and
then they get more like so they have
math animals do like stuff animals do
before their owner pulls them away real
quick I heard that a lot of these girls
with their when they're interacting with
people online they're not really doing
it that they hire a company and then
someone writes these letters because
like if you feel like you're gonna
respond to people and text them like how
many of them are you gonna do this to
like how many can you how many days I
mean how much hours in the day do you
have and if people don't know how many
you're responding to or who's doing it
like if you have like say if you have a
million subscribers on only fans and you
get a hundred thousand messages a month
yeah you gotta have somebody helping you
maybe they just have a person like a
service who writes like sexy things like
thank you sweetie heart heart yeah kiss
blowing kiss you know yeah like yeah
you're so sweet thank you and he's a fat
guy writing those things
you know you [__] in and only fans video
so you're like kind of like a porn guy
yeah that's not as cool
so you just [__] in an only fans video
and she's cashing in
and you're taxinger can you please take
that down that's
are you really in a only fans video
are you are you proud of how you're
looking at dude do you have a big dong
did you did you say do you describe your
penis as fantastic
I've never heard that in my life
do you have a nice piece it's wonderful
it's really good
what kind of work are you in
that sucks you don't get residuals for
your music or your [__]
the girls can go on only fans [__] pile
of money just showing their feet exactly
feet in their butthole take your feet
out of those [__] Sketchers or
whatever they were wearing wear a stick
stick a carrot up your ass with bunny
ears on and you'll make so much more
money than you ever would in Playboy
dude
is wild because I've talked to people
that are on the only fans I'm like how
much money you making just tell me good
[__] 10 000 a month 100 000 a month
50 000 a month and they just they're
just taking pictures and they're regular
girls like no one knows who they are and
they're making a million a year but I
also think about the girl who goes
because I think in in the back of every
hot girl's head they're like I could
make millions of dollars stripping but I
choose not to and there's a couple that
have started an only fans and it didn't
work out yeah oh really yeah 180 a month
what I don't know for every girl that's
getting 10 000 there's one that's
getting 180 bucks so imagine you show
the goods in your whole life you were
like I'm above this right it's a hundred
eighty dollars a month one shift waiting
tables at the store
um yeah how does one become famous on
only fans right that's the question
that's the social climbing [__] that
like I'm not I don't even want to call
social climbing but like
I find it very hard to engage creatively
with people that I don't respect
and some people are really good at it
like they find other people that are
like popping and they can like insert
themselves in
and
um
I just can't do it you got to pull the
microphone down a couple guys in the top
15 earners yeah they're making money
guys yeah what are they doing showing
[__]
tiger makes a lot I think I heard he's
got a piece and then Aaron Carter is on
there right he apparently has a piece
though I don't know why I know that he
shows his [__] I think so I I I'm not
checking I don't know what else to pay
for whatever right don't they leak yeah
they definitely that's the [__] up
[__] is reddit is fun yeah
that feels so bad saying this but like
if ever there's a friend of mine that's
on holy fans or someone I kind of know
like from the peripheral I go right to
Reddit and it's there dude so is Reddit
like or is only fans for people that
don't know how to use the real internet
yeah you're just old it's for Boomers
yeah
love with the girl and you want to
support her that's the thing if she's
showing it there's a lot of those guys
that like become super fascinating with
those girls and then they want to meet
them and do you know that it's all
rigged when I spoke to this only fans
girls they have people who text the guys
oh so these these chicks this is the
game right the girls go with the company
the company takes all their pictures
populates their only fans oh there's a
new company that does that there's
companies that do this right they're
like an agency they take like 25 they
take all your pictures fly to La do all
the things and then they have people who
interact with your fans and talk sexy to
them and say I can't wait to see you so
they keep you engaged and then you
[__] fall in love with them oh boy
and then the girls don't gotta do [__]
wow yeah that's sad yeah that's sad
those guys are getting hustled they are
but are they I think they know it it's
like the catfish [__] it's like you know
it's fake but you like the fact that
someone's talking to you saying they
love you the solution is a video the
girl has to make a video She Gotta make
a video directly to you hi Mike I really
appreciate you jerking off to my feet
the next one that I take that carrot is
gonna be cut my ass for a year you're
only gonna see green yeah you're just
gonna see the carrot the green and my
feet
I like to feed [__] though I'm not gonna
laugh yeah I like pretty feet you made a
lot busted feet are sad what is this
Tiger's genitals netted him 7.9 million
there you go he's doubling down on only
fans wow
is Tyga still doing music
I don't know but when you got it like
that like 7.9 million just showing his
hog
bruh making money you find out what you
really love how much why is the game
slipping why is he nodding on that why
because he got a piece right he's got an
arm but he's medium swole like I don't
think that's fake I think he's I don't
think it's hard enough where it's facing
up but I think he warms it up to the
point it doesn't matter he's got a piece
he got a piece dude you got a piece bro
yeah it's one of them pythons it
swallows alligators it's a problem you
fill that thing up with water you go to
the gym that's a hop yeah yeah he got a
nice little heart he's got like a shin
bone in there
like that give that [__] to Connor just
replace it
just replace god with [__] the games
our criminal friends Devin and I to own
a small
purse crypto little wallet right a
couple hundred bucks I think you have a
couple hundred dollars and they watch
the crypto market like like our friend
Ida watches the market like her life
depends on it
and she's just on the edge of her seat
watching this
and just reading and studying she could
make so much more money on only fans
just show the gash but she's trying to
learn about uh cryptocurrencies in
Central Banking
Central Banking show your ass
she's attractive
stop talking about fiat currency show
your feet and earn a living
now
I keep telling her that
I've told a lot of my friends and I
don't mean anything nasty by this in
fact I wish someone would tell me this
but we know why they're not going to
because you know I have a very I have a
specific look I've told many of my
friends you should become a prostitute
you should have sex for money
are you not listening to me
well I'm thinking about at well the Fiat
current have sex with strangers and have
them pay you